Bonjour tout le monde, je
m'appelle Véronique Prince, je
suis correspondante
parlementaire pour Radio-Canada
depuis 2012 et je fais partie
des caravaniers qui suit cette
campagne électorale au jour le
jour et aujourd'hui on fait ce
Facebook live pour pouvoir
répondre à vos questions parce
qu'on voit qu'elles sont
nombreuses sur les différents
réseaux sociaux vous voulez
savoir un petit peu comment se
passe notre vie de caravaniers
on va être là pour vous
l'expliquer je vais vous
présenter euh en fait euh mes
quatre collègues on peut
peut-être commencer par Jacques
Audrey si tu veux euh te
présenter aux gens. je
m'appelle Jacques Audrey
Charbonneau, je suis
journaliste à Radio-Canada au
Téléjournal et euh j'en suis à
ma première euh campagne et
depuis deux semaines je couvre,
je suis en fait la caravane de
Québec Solidaire et euh je vais
bientôt passer euh à partir de
ce soir euh aux conservateurs.
Bonjour tout le monde,
Alexandre Duval, je suis
correspondant parlementaire à
l'Assemblée nationale depuis
quelques mois déjà, j'en suis
aussi à ma première campagne
électorale je couvre euh
l'autobus de la Coalition
Avenir Québec avec le chef
François Legault depuis le
début de la campagne. À partir
de ce soir ce sera avec les
libéraux et madame Anglade.
Sébastien Desrosiers, je suis
euh journaliste au euh
Téléjournal euh Montréal. Euh
quant à moi c'est ma deuxième
campagne première campagne euh
électorale provinciale. Je suis
à bord de l'autobus du Parti
Conservateur du Québec avec le
chef Éric Duhaime depuis deux
semaines. Et à partir de ce
soir, euh je serai avec le le
chef du Parti Québécois Paul
St-Pierre Plamondon. Bonjour
Valérie Gama, je suis euh
correspondante parlementaire à
Otte prêté donc euh à cette
belle campagne provinciale mais
j'ai déjà été dans le passé
donc correspondante
parlementaire à Québec. J'ai
couvert d'ailleurs le dernier
mandat euh donc la 42e
législature donc je connais un
peu les enjeux quand même qui
euh qui qui qui on va le dire
se révèlent pendant cette
campagne-là et euh depuis le
début je suis donc la caravane
péquiste avec Paul St-Pierre
Plamondon et là je vais prendre
la place de Jacques-Audrey dans
le bus des solidaires.
D'ailleurs je pense que c'est
important de spécifier que
c'est la première dans
l'histoire qu'on est cinq là.
Parce qu'habituellement pour
faire ces Facebook live là, les
autres campagnes on était deux,
trois caravaniers mais on voit
vraiment que ça a changé l'axe
souverainiste euh fédéraliste
là, c'est complètement
différent. Pis là on se
retrouve avec des partis sur
tout le spectre politique et
c'est pour ça qu'on est cinq
aujourd'hui et pour moi c'est
particulier de faire cette
conversation-là à cinq. Et ce
sera en évidence ce soir au
face à face. Oui euh oui. La
première jeux télévisée de la
campagne, cinq chefs. Ça fera
euh beaucoup de temps pour
exposer ses idées. Non.
Peut-être de la cacophonie. Va
falloir faire attention à ça.
Euh ben justement ça m'amène à
dire aux gens qui peuvent nous
poser des questions en temps
réel, on va les prendre et tout
ça. Pis je vois que la première
question de France Gagnon euh
tombe à point là parce que vous
avez tous nommé sur quelle
caravane vous étiez les deux
premières semaines, sur quelle
caravane vous allez les deux
prochaines. Pis justement elles
nous demandent ben est-ce que
vous changez de caravane en
milieu de campagne? La réponse
c'est oui, mais je pense qu'on
pourrait expliquer pourquoi en
fait c'était important de
changer de caravane. Ben c'est
important pour plusieurs
raisons Véronique parce qu'on
s'habitue à à travailler avec
les mêmes personnes. On on est
très près aussi, on devient
prêt et du chef et de de de son
staff politique. Pis un moment
donné on a plus nécessairement
plus la vision d'ensemble parce
qu'on est dans une bulle. Hum.
C'est un peu ça là. On est
vraiment comme dans notre bulle
pis on a pas toujours le temps
quand on arrive à 11 heures le
soir de récupérer toutes les
bulletins de nouvelles qui sont
faits. On n'a pas donc ça nous
faut faut vraiment repartir à
neuf pour être pour assurer je
pense la meilleure équipe.
D'autres questions aussi
parfois tu sais de pouvoir
poser, d'avoir un regard un peu
extérieur pis de pouvoir poser
d'autres questions au chef. Je
pense que le changement de
caravane même si j'en suis à ma
première, ça peut amener ça un
regard un peu plus frais euh
sur une campagne qui euh qui
des fois repart à à nouveau
avec un un rendez-vous comme ce
soir, un débat, tout ça. On
remet le compteur à zéro dans
le fond. Exact. Pis qu'on le
veuille ou non aussi que le
chef finit par s'habituer un
petit peu aux journalistes qui
sont à bord de l'autobus, au
style des journalistes des fois
ils voient un petit peu les
questions venir et on le sent,
donc après deux semaines
d'aller euh changer de caravane
comme ça, je pense que c'est
aussi déstabilisant pour les
chefs qui vont devoir
s'habituer à des nouveaux
styles de questions, peut-être
des angles auxquels ils avaient
pas été exposés jusqu'à
maintenant et j'en profite pour
saluer madame Gagnon qui
m'écrit de temps en temps sur
Twitter d'ailleurs. C'est vrai
on reconnaît les les gens qui
nous écrivent. Oui. Mais ça
permet de changer d'air hein de
dans l'autobus parce quà un
moment donné euh à ce cette
période-ci là au jour seize,
dix-sept, dix-huit. On entre
dans un espèce de brouillard
pis justement on se demande,
mais quelle question j'ai pas
déjà posée. Alors le fait qu'un
collègue vienne nous relayer
ben c'est un nouveau souffle.
Ouais ben ça permet aussi euh
comme Jacques-Audrey le disait
de d'offrir une nouvelle
perspective pis des fois de de
changer d'air euh sans dire que
les conférences de presse sont
confrontationnelles, mais des
fois, il y a des questions qui
reviennent euh euh bon euh les
les chefs sont peut-être tannés
de de les de les recevoir donc
ça permet de euh de de c'est ça
de repartir à zéro, changement
de dynamique c'est ça avec de
nouvelles personnalités autour
de nous, ça peut faire du bien
à tout le monde je crois. Pis
avant de continuer avec les
autres questions, je j'en
aurais une pour euh Valérie pis
Sébastien parce que ce qui est
particulier dans votre cas pour
les deux premières semaines de
campagnes c'est que vous étiez
dans le même autobus que le
chef parce que pour que les
gens comprennent à la maison,
généralement pour chaque partie
il y a deux autobus. Il y a
l'autobus du chef, il y a
l'autobus avec les médias, mais
dans du parti conservateur et
du Parti Québécois, il y a un
seul autobus, c'est-à-dire que
les journalistes côtoient
toujours le chef et son
personnel politique. Alors je
sais pas si vous pouvez nous
expliquer la dynamique que ça a
créé parce que euh pis est-ce
qu'il y a une cloison, quelque
chose qui vous sépare? Ben je
sais pas pour tout le monde il
y a pas physiquement, il y a il
y a il y a pas de cloison avec
le stade. Non, il y a pas de
porte. Non, il y a une cloison,
c'est-à-dire que les
journalistes on est installé en
avant là dans la première
portion. Ensuite il y a une
espèce de petite cuisine Ça y
est ça dans tous les cas
mais pis là après cette petite
cuisine-là là qui est aussi le
le mini bureau imprimante là,
là il y a le staff politique
qui est là. Là il y a il y a
vraiment là les organisateurs
coordonnateurs de campagnes pis
après là il y a une petite loge
pour le chef pis dans cette
loge-là ben c'est là qu'il va
recevoir tu sais ses candidats,
c'est là qu'il fait ses
réunions d'équipe, c'est là
qu'il reçoit aussi tu sais des
anciens ou en tout cas dans le
cas du PQ est-ce que vous
entendez pas sauf que tu vois
tout le temps les gens qui
rentrent qui sortent, fait que
là tu dis okay là euh euh on
est rendu mettons à Rimouski
pis Pascal Bérubé est encore
là. Comment ça Pascal nous suit
jusqu'ici? Fait que là alors
que normalement on le verrait
pas Pascal en une rentrée
sortir ou la logique est fermée
mais sauf que tu le vois
passer. On voit une partie de
la stratégie Non c'est ça. Ben
oui t'as pas le choix. Parce
que parce que avec le le parti
conservateur c'est un peu la
même chose, c'est-à-dire qu'on
est assis en avant là à notre
euh notre bureau. Il y a pas de
cuisine comme je l'ai mentionné
mais cloison une porte et euh
moi c'est une dynamique que
j'ai bien apprécié pendant les
deux premières semaines parce
que dès qu'on avait une
question euh pour ou pour
quelqu'un de son équipe on
avait quà cogner à la porte
puis euh habituellement il y
avait pas de problème. Bien
pour les journalistes peut-être
que les chefs apprécient moins
je dirais pas ça parce que dans
le cas en tout cas du Parti
Québécois le fait qu'on puisse
tout de suite aller les voir
pis dire euh eh ça moi je
sincèrement vous êtes tu sais
il y a quelque chose là que je
comprends pas tu sais euh pis
ça ça marche pas avec ce que
vous avez déjà dit pis là des
fois ça ça prend une couple de
kilomètres là et tu sais ils
vont ils vont se rassembler
avec le chef la question est
réglée pis on a une réponse tu
sais est-ce que vous vous êtes
sentis observés parfois par
l'équipe autour du chef? Parce
que nous en étant dans un
autobus séparé il y a moins cet
enjeu-là. Des fois bon on sent
quand même une présence euh on
sent quand même une présence
vous avez dit vous n'en avez
c'est ça vous avez dit un oeuf
quand même. Mais c'est sûr que
tu parles moins fort là moi je
dirais euh ben quand on fait un
direct c'est ça t'as t'as
l'impression que quelqu'un
est-ce que c'est intimidant
d'avoir le chef dans son
autobus? Ben je dirais pas ça.
Non. Euh non j'ai trouvé ça
comme plus pratique qu'autre
chose mais c'est sûr que quand
on sait qu'il est derrière pis
qu'il entend euh ce qu'il dit
ben je veux dire on parle à la
télé donc on sait qu'il va
savoir ce qu'on dit de toute
façon euh non j'ai trouvé ça
plus pratique qu'autre chose
moi depuis le début de la
campagne c'est sûr que pis tu
sais moi j'appelle ça les
discussions tu sais les
discussions de fin de journée
les discussions de vieux poêle
là tu sais euh où là les choses
que tu dirais que que tu dirais
pas nécessairement en ondes là
mais qu'un moment donné t'as
besoin de débriefer avec les
collègues ça tu sens euh tu
sais là tu parles tout bas pis
là t'espère qu'il entend pas
pis donc nous on avait un petit
code euh dans l'autobus euh
solidaire quand on voulait pas
trop que les l'équipe entende.
On disait ah oui la sécurité
nautique c'est très important
changer de cas dans le code.
Okay on va changer de code okay
j'aimerais peut-être que euh
vous nous décriviez Alexandre
Jean-Caudry euh la journée type
d'un caravani en fait c'est
quoi? Ça commence quand même
tôt le matin, ça finit tard le
soir juste pour que les gens
comprenne le travail d'une
journée type. Avec monsieur
Legault, je dirais que depuis
le début, les journées se sont
beaucoup ressemblées à venir
jusqu'à jusqu'à il y a quelques
jours seulement. Généralement,
le départ le matin se faisait
entre 7 h et demie, 8 heures et
demie, une première annonce qui
se faisait assez tôt le matin,
et ça, vous remarquerez, la CAQ
presque chaque jour était le
premier parti à faire son
annonce. Pour dicter l'agenda.
Voilà, et ça c'était pas,
c'était pas un choix fortuit
là, c'était pas parce que
monsieur Legault aime plus ça
se lever de bonne heure que les
mais il y avait cette idée-là
de partir la journée avec une
annonce qui allait prendre euh
les devants sur les annonces
des autres partis. Généralement
lors de cette annonce-là qui
était présentée en point de
presse, on avait donc
l'occasion d'avoir une période
de questions ça on pourra y
revenir mais ça a chauffé un
petit peu avec l'équipe
Caquiste parce qu'on était
limité dans le nombre de
questions qu'on pouvait poser
au début de la campagne pis euh
ça frotter un peu avec les
journalistes par la suite
souvent un dîner militant donc
on se rendait dans un resto un
bar, un lieu public pour
rencontrer des gens qui
militent pour la CAQ avec des
candidats locaux et en
après-midi généralement on
avait une deuxième annonce. Il
y en a eu à peu près deux par
jour encore une fois venir
jusqu'à il y a quelques jours.
Et euh l'après-midi par contre
les questions étaient en
formule SWM donc en formule
mêlée de presse. Ça c'est un
peu quand les journalistes se
parlent les uns par dessus les
autres. Ça devient ben voilà.
Donc celui qui parle le plus
fort réussi à faire entendre sa
question. Donc on a on a eu
quand même beaucoup d'occasions
de questionner mais on avait
pas d'activités en soirée. Ah!
Avec monsieur Legault. en a eu
euh honnêtement je pense qu'on
en a pas eu une. Et il y en
avait peut-être plus avec
Québec Solidaire pis qui
faisaient des rassemblements.
Connaissez de voir euh la la
différence de dynamique pis je
pense que c'est très propre au
chef parce que Québec Solidaire
commençait plus tard. Beaucoup
plus tard ses journées. Est-ce
que c'est parce que Gabriel
Nadeau-Dubois, jeune papa
passait du temps avec sa
famille? C'est peut-être une
partie de l'explication. On m'a
aussi dit que à l'époque de
Philippe Couillard qui se
levait très tôt, euh les
journées commençaient très tôt
mais terminaient tôt également.
Euh avec euh SWA ont commencé
plus tard et euh c'est un peu
comme euh comme ce qu'Alexandre
a dit, c'est-à-dire on avait
une annonce donc on faisait les
annonces euh à ce moment-là. On
prenait les questions des
journalistes par la suite on
faisait beaucoup de routes, il
y avait d'autres activités avec
des candidats justement dans
des rassemblements militants et
euh Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois aussi
aime beaucoup se prêter à
l'exercice de l'assemblée
populaire. Il y en a eu quatre
dans différentes villes,
souvent se sont en territoire
déjà conquis, mais quand même,
il prend des questions du
public. Ça donne lieu à des
échanges. Euh donc il y a et ça
c'était souvent en soirée là
entre 19 heures et vingtet-une
heures donc peut-être que la
journée se terminait un peu
plus tard mais elle commençait
aussi euh un peu plus tard là
chez Québec Solidaire. Tu vois
nous ça commençait tôt au PQ tu
sais je passe le message Ça
commence très tôt, ça finit
sept heures. Beaucoup le soir.
Ouais. Nous on commence ouais.
Les annonces souvent entre 8 et
9. Pis ensuite euh le soir
rassemblement pis euh c'est
arrivé souvent là quand on est
arrivé à 10 entre dix et onze
heures à l'hôtel là. Ben des
journées de douze, treize,
quatorze, 15 heures finalement,
c'est vraiment pas rare. En
campagne électorales pas mal
non? Ouais toi t'en as eu. T'en
as eu? Oui quand même moi
j'étais avec le Parti Libéral
pis je vais prendre tout de
suite une question d'Alain
Lamarre qui est en quand même
en lien avec ce qu'on dit là
qui veut savoir si on est
restreint à un certain secret
politique dans les autobus euh
secret politique moi je dirais
que non. C'est-à-dire qu'on on
oui il peut y avoir un embargo
par exemple on nous avertit
d'une annonce qui s'en vient
pis on nous dit ben l'annonce
est à dix heures alors euh
avant dix heures on vous
demande de pas en parler mais
on vous le donne à l'avance
pour que vous puissiez vous
préparer, préparer vos
questions. Autrement euh je
sais pas vous, mais moi il y a
pas du tout de secret politique
là, c'est-à-dire qu'on rapporte
ce qu'on voit là. Ouais, ben il
peut je veux dire c'est une
réalité de notre métier, y
avoir des conversations qui
sont off the Record comme on
dit. Euh j'ai l'impression que
c'est plus rare en campagne
électorale ben ça peut arriver
un chef par exemple qui arrive
dans l'autobus qui dit okay là
je vais vous dire euh euh je
vais vous dire euh bon le fond
de la pensée euh mais je vous
avertis cette cette
discussion-là va être offert.
Hum hum. Pis à partir de là ben
on a le choix d'accepter ou non
euh les terme de de de de cette
conversation-là euh je sais par
exemple que durant la dernière
campagne fédérale, monsieur
Trudeau s'était présenté dans
dans l'avion euh devant les
médias pis avait demandé à
avoir une conversation offert
pis je sais qu'il y avait des
médias euh qui avaient refusé
de participer à cette
conversation-là puisqu'il ne
voulait pas euh être contraint
euh au secret politique pour
reprendre cette je sais pas si
je je saisis bien le sens de la
question de monsieur mais on a
pas eu beaucoup de moments
d'intimité avec le chef euh
François Legault étant donné
qu'on est pas sur le même
autobus que lui. Hum hum. On
l'a vu lors de ses sorties.
Donc on l'a vu lors de ses
interactions avec les
militants, avec les candidats,
avec les citoyens. Il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se
disent pendant ces
événements-là, mais qui sont
pas forcément d'intérêt public
là. Monsieur Legault, à
quelques reprises, il a dit des
choses qui étaient très
cocasses, c'était rigolo, ben
vous le connaissez là, comme
personnage politique euh. Il
lui arrive des fois de dire des
choses qui euh peuvent
drôlement paraître là un moment
donné euh bon il était dans un
rassemblement pis euh il y
avait un petit garçon, une
petite fille qui était là, pis
ben il a pensé que c'était
petites filles pis là ça a créé
un petit malaise sur le coup.
Bon vous voyez le genre mais ça
c'est pas d'intérêt public sauf
que il y a pas de si on avait
eu de l'intimité euh des des
des repas partagés autour d'une
table avec le chef pis que là
il s'était ouvert sur sa
perception de certains enjeux
ou certaines choses. Euh pis
quà ce moment-là ça avait été
clair que c'est une
conversation offert. Ben
clairement on aurait respecté
cette entente-là mais je peux
pas dire qu'il y a des secrets
dont on est au courant qu'on ne
révèle pas. En tout cas pas euh
pas sur ma caravane. Alors il y
a des choses qui se Il y a des
choses qui je dirais par
respect un moment donné pis là
je là je reviens à, on a fait
un article euh Jacques-Audrey,
Véro et moi sur les papas, les
jeunes papas et mamans, les
être parents tu sais l'espèce
de concession moi j'ai fait
l'entrevue avec euh Paul
Saint-Paul à Mona en ce
moment-là pis c'est un c'est un
tu sais c'est un c'est un papa
PSP là tu sais pis là au début
il voulait pas en parler parce
qu'il se disait je veux pas
paraître comme d'une victime.
Hum. Alors
il y a comme un il y a comme un
truc tu dis non mais le but le
but c'est le pass on veut pas
on veut pas on veut pas tu sais
le but c'est pas t'as de l'air
du gars qui se plaint pis alors
tu sais ça mais c'est pas des
c'est pas des secrets
politiques c'est juste des tu
dis ben regarde parce que
parfois il faut être interprété
comme une voilà politique voilà
on entend beaucoup de
commentaires justement se
reprendre des bébés dans des
des ça fait partie de la de la
joute politique entre
guillemets et Gabrielle
Nadeau-Dubois qu'on entend pas
souvent non plus sur sa vie
personnelle lui-même avoue
avoir
une certaine pudeur par rapport
à ça et depuis qu'il est euh
chef parlementaire,
co-porte-parole, essaie de
s'ouvrir depuis qu'il est papa,
essaie de s'ouvrir un peu à ça.
Donc il y a cette cette
dynamique-là qui est à à
trouver un peu la limite, la
frontière aussi entre tout ça
pis euh j'ai euh William
McManiman, j'espère que je
prononce bien votre nom qui
veut justement poursuivre là
sur ce thème-là en nous
demandant si on est soumis à un
embargo sur certaines
informations, au thème, ben
comme on le disait à l'approche
d'une
savoir aussi euh est-ce que il
y a des choses que vous avez eu
connaissance plus tôt en
campagne électorale mais que
vous avez tardé avant d'en
parler? Moi j'aurais tendance à
dire peut-être l'itinéraire
parce que c'est quand même une
stratégie politique des partis
leur itinéraire veulent pas
nécessairement que les
adversaires le sachent mais
nous on le sait parce que on
doit se préparer là en terme de
logistique. Ben moi je pense
que dans dans cette campagne-ci
pis c'est c'est ça
on avait tous remarqué la
sécurité. Oui. On avait tous
tous remarqué la première
journée. On s'en est tous par
la première journée pis on on
en a pas parlé tout de suite.
On a été ouais c'est ça. On a
on a on a attendu un peu avant
avant d'en parler pis ça ça euh
ça c'est vrai qu'on a mais je
pense tous médias confondus là.
Il y a plusieurs euh ben ce qui
arrive c'est que souvent on a
besoin de savoir à quel endroit
on va dormir le lendemain ou le
surlendemain parce que là les
gens le savent pas forcément
mais quand on part on part en
se mettant en tête qu'on part
pour 36 ou 37 jours. SW
qu'est-ce qu'on met dans ce
vaccin? Qu'on aura pas la
dans mon cas de savoir à quelle
date je vais repasser par
Québec pour être capable de
faire du lavage, ben le parti
va me le dire, mais moi je
dirai pas ben on revient à
Québec telle date. Exact. Par
contre euh il y a quelque chose
que je je sais pas si vous
l'avez vécu mais justement sur
l'enjeu stratégique de
l'itinéraire, moi il est arrivé
à deux reprises depuis le début
de la campagne que des attacher
d'autres autobus me contactent
pour me demander à quelle date
ou à quel moment vous allez
être
oui pis ça c'est intéressant
parce que ça ça ça indique au
public que nous-mêmes on est
soumis à certaines forces
contraires. Parfois on tente de
nous soutirer de l'information.
Mais on en donne pas par contre
Je pense que c'est important de
le dire. Ben exact, moi je joue
pas. Oui on peut ben on testait
ma naïveté je crois. Euh mais
on peut pas jouer dans ce
film-là parce quà partir du
moment où on déciderait de dire
ah ben je pense qu'ils vont
être à telle place demain. Là
ça pourrait donner un avantage
un avantage stratégique à
l'autre partie. Donc clair
embarque
pas là-dedans, il y a
certaines choses qu'on sait et
qu'on doit garder pour nous euh
sur l'itinéraire parce que
c'est des enjeux stratégiques
pour les partis, c'est clair.
On a une question de Patrick
Laplante qui nous demande
est-ce qu'on a senti une
variation dans l'enthousiasme
de l'équipe qu'on suit depuis
le début de la campagne? Si
oui, de quelle nature et est-ce
que vous avez noté un point
tournant? C'est sûr que Éric
Duhaime quand il y a plein
d'histoires qui sont qui ont
commencé à sortir, ça a duré
deux, trois, quatre jours.
Justement sur euh ces taxes non
payées et tout ça.
que tu l'as senti toi Sébastien
euh dans l'humeur du chef et
ton ouais il y a eu un
changement de je dirais
d'ambiance euh à bord de
l'autobus euh je disais un peu
plus tôt que qu'il était facile
au cours des dernières semaines
d'aller cogner à sa porte puis
de lui poser une question
depuis vendredi c'est un peu
moins facile. Euh euh pis là on
a compris bon vendredi quand
euh cette première histoire est
sortie est parue dans le
Journal de Québec à l'effet
qu'il n'avait pas payé ses
taxes euh foncières euh ces
dernières années. Euh il y
avait visiblement un malaise là
euh chez euh chez monsieur
Duhaime qui était dans un
rassemblement ce soir-là. Euh
on lui a demandé
de de répondre à nos questions
euh à la caméra et euh il y a
jamais eu de problème. Monsieur
Dum est toujours très euh euh
comment dire partant oui c'est
ça pour répondre à nos
questions même que dans les
conférences de presse
contrairement à certains autres
partis on est pas limité du
moins de façon formelle. À à
deux questions alors que cette
fois-là il a accepté de
répondre à une question pis il
s'est engouffré dans l'autobus.
Euh la même chose est arrivée
euh lundi je crois mardi là
quand euh on on a appris
maintenant que c'était ses
taxes scolaires qui n'avaient
pas été payées pendant deux
ans. Là il a carrément refusé
de répondre à nos questions
avant de s'expliquer le
alors oui il y a eu un euh un
changement d'atmosphère je
dirais un malaise. Maintenant
on comprend que c'était dû à la
relation qu'il avait avec son
locataire comme comme il nous
l'a expliqué là euh ou du
moins. C'est c'est ce qu'il
c'est ce qu'il a expliqué. Moi
j'aurais envie de de poser la
question à Véronique en fait
avec qui a eu un départ plutôt
difficile. Est-ce que on on la
voyait toujours martelée que ça
allait bien tout ça mais on le
sentait quand même. En fait on
a tellement une proximité avec
les chefs et le personnel
politique que quand ça va bien
on
on le sent, on le voit
automatiquement sur le terrain,
on est capable de le rapporter.
Ça paraît même quand ils
rencontrent les gens dans les
bains de foule là. Il y a
beaucoup d'éléments qui font en
sorte qu'on le voit quand ça va
bien. Beaucoup d'éléments aussi
qui font en sorte qu'on le voit
quand ça va quand ça va moins
bien là. Tu sais même si ils
vont pas nous le dire
spécifiquement on le remarque
dans dans l'attitude, ça il y a
aucun doute là-dessus. Pis je
j'aimerais peut-être qu'on
aborde une question parce que
je je moi en tout cas
personnellement je me je me la
fais souvent poser sur les
réseaux sociaux. La question
de l'indépendance des
journalistes parfois j'ai
l'impression que les gens
pensent qu'on embarque sur les
autobus, qu'on va à l'hôtel,
qu'on se fait tout payer par le
parti alors que c'est pas le
cas donc c'est ça je sais pas
si un de vous veut aborder
justement cette cet aspect
d'indépendance là là moi juste
euh compléter sur le tu sais le
changement de changement de ton
parce que pour le Parti Québec
ois c'est c'est c'est
particulier parce que ils ont
ils ont débuté la la campagne
tu sais tout le monde disait le
parti est mort il y a une il va
rester un député pis c'est
Pascal Bérubé pis euh tu sais
PSPP était pas connu. Pis là
eux c'est le contraire. Hum
hum. Tu sais il y a eu un
switch là pour la première
semaine où là tu sais dans
plusieurs émissions euh Paul
Saint-Pierre pis on était comme
l'étoile de la là on a on a
senti la la tu sais la la le
changement là pis le changement
d'attitude pis on a senti aussi
le chef tu sais ce bomber un
peu le galvanise un peu les
troubles. Oui oui oui ou là
c'est comme okay ouf tu sais ça
ça comme ça a comme donné un un
petit un petit air d'aller
alors que depuis le début on a
l'impression que tu sais ça a
marché comme un tu sais comme
un petit chat là qui avance pis
qui se dit mon Dieu comment ça
va? Pis là vraiment il y a eu
un c'est ça un air d'aller donc
à l'inverse là de de toi là moi
j'ai vraiment vécu un hum hum
une espèce de prise de de de de
confiance je dirais de la c'est
ça pis on est on est privilégié
d'être aux premières loges pour
voir ça là. Ouais. Mais comme
je le disais euh on reste quand
même euh très neutre et
indépendant par rapport au
travail qu'on fait là euh.
Ouais pis c'est drôle parce que
un rassemblement à Lévis il y a
un partisan conservateur qui
m'a demandé comment vous avez
choisi euh tu sais sur sur quel
autobus sur quelle caravane
allait se retrouver quel
journaliste est-ce que c'est en
fonction de de vos allégeances
politiques on a pas choisi ben
on a pas choisi c'est ça c'est
comme si notre nom avait été
dans un chapeau c'est ça exact
faudrait c'est la question
qu'il faudrait poser à nos
patrons en fait ouais c'est ça
non euh la les gens se posent
la question on paie nos hôtels
on paie nos repas on paye pour
être sur l'autobus donc c'est
pas comme si c'était eux qui
nous payaient être là, c'est en
fait c'est l'inverse. Exact. Et
euh on paye nos repas, on paye
notre place, on paye tout là.
Oui oui. Pis quand on sent que
les relations peuvent devenir
difficiles entre l'équipe du
parti et l'équipe de
journalistes. Il y a quand même
un esprit de corps qui se forme
et je sais pas si vous l'avez
senti sur vos caravanes
respectives sur divers enjeux.
Mais quand on vit des problèmes
avec le parti, qu'on voudrait
peut-être pas nous donner accès
à tel ou tel truc. Euh ben on
l'exige parce qu'on paye pour
être là paye pour pouvoir
suivre le chef. Il y a un
travail d'équipe de
journalistes
dans la caravane solidaire. Un
moment donné on voulait avoir
accès une deuxième fois à
Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois. On
justement et l'argument de base
ça a été de de de se mettre
ensemble pis de dire euh on on
paie de l'argent pour être ici.
On a des demandes, on a des
impératifs différents des
vôtres. Pis vous nous donnez
accès à votre chef une deuxième
fois durant la journée. Peu
importe si vous êtes en retard
ou non, c'est pas notre
problème si on est en retard
dans l'itinéraire. Donc des
fois les les relations peuvent
tu sais le ton peut monter mais
au final ça redevient toujours
un peu cordel. Je pense que ça
fait partie un peu de la joie.
De la game de la joute
politique. C'est ça. L'aspect
logistique je trouve ça
intéressant parce que
particulièrement nous qui
sommes à la télé avons euh des
impératifs logistiques
c'est-à-dire quà 17 heures et
à dix-huit heures
habituellement qu'on a des
directs on doit être dans un
endroit où euh on a du réseau
euh ouais. Si l'horaire
prévoyait qu'on était là moi
j'ai donné rendez-vous à mon
cameraman à à cet endroit là
euh et là finalement 30 minutes
plus tôt on me dit eh
finalement euh on est en
retard. On a changé à tel
endroit pis je dis non non
c'est c'est pas que ça qui
était prévu pis après tout ils
veulent qu'on qu'on parle d'eux
euh c'est ça. Téléjournal c'est
pour ça que eux dictent tout
là. Il y en a une partie que
c'est c'est nous aussi. Pis
d'ailleurs j'ai j'ai une
anecdote peut-être là-dessus
là. Hum par rapport à
l'indépendance des médias,
l'autobus médiatique n'a pas de
logo du parti. C'est un le
l'autobus du chef évidemment il
y a la photo du chef et tout ça
mais l'autobus médiatique n'en
a pas. Moi j'ai déjà été de la
tribune de la presse au
parlement, ça c'est
l'association qui représente
les les journalistes à
l'Assemblée nationale. Pis je
me rappelle qu'un parti en 2018
était arrivé avec un autobus
médiatique avec Legault. Et là
on avait dit le CA avec moi, on
avait dit nous n'embarquons pas
dans l'autobus. Tant que vous
n'enlevez pas les logos et ils
avaient été obligés de
retourner l'autobus au garage,
de changer leur itinéraire,
changer leur horaire du jour,
parce qu'il fallait aller
enlever les logos, pis ça
prenait un 2 3 heures. Ben
c'est ça la différence ça de
Sébastien là quand on débarque
de l'autobus là oui les gens
pensent qu'on est tu sais les
gens pensent qu'on est avec le
parti parce que il y a un seul
autobus moi il y a des gens là
qui sont venus qui sont venus
me remercier là tu sais des
candidats qui viennent te voir
pis qui te remercient du
soutien que le parti leur
rapporte tu fais non mais vous
direz à monsieur vous le direz
vous-même tu sais c'est
délicat. Mais donc dans notre
cas c'est pis c'est c'est ça
c'est délicat parce que tu
parles des logos pis euh sur
l'autobus conservateur c'est
une petite anecdote il y a la
le visage de monsieur Duhaime
pis on le voit à travers les
les fenêtres. Alors quand je
fais des direct dans l'autobus,
il y a monsieur Duhym qui me
regarde. j'ai une autre
question intéressante de
Patrick Laplante pis euh
peut-être que ça pourrait être
notre dernière question. Puis
je je la trouve très pertinente
parce que je sais qu'il y a
beaucoup de monde qui se le
demande. Est-ce que la
proximité engendrée par cette
expérience-là qu'on vit ça
influence notre choix électoral
je vous demande pas de
mentionner pour qui vous allez
voter euh à ce que ça peut
effectivement euh jouer dans
votre tête? Et je pense que ça
joue dans la perception qu'on a
des personnages politiques, des
des politiciennes et
politiciennes qu'on suit euh le
monsieur Le que je vois au
quotidien c'est pas le monsieur
Legault que je voyais à
l'Assemblée nationale. Donc
j'ai découvert des aspects de
sa personnalité que je ne
soupçonnais pas euh de là à
dire pis là je m'en vais avec
les libéraux, de là à dire que
la personnalité que je perçois
chez le chef au quotidien
pourrait influencer ce que moi
comme citoyen je ferai comme
choix le 3 octobre euh non. Moi
j'ai l'impression que ça me
rend plus vigilante en fait
encore d'être vraiment
là-dedans pis de pas se laisser
euh comme on dit dans le dans
le jargon euh j'ai l'impression
que moi ça me rend plus
vigilante puis euh je je
ressens même pis j'avais déjà
entendu euh Sébastien Bovet
parler du fait qu'il annulait
son vote lui parce qu'il se
jugeait trop proche pis je j'ai
l'impression que je me sens
aussi peut-être des fois un peu
comme ça je me je me sentirais
trahir un peu mon mon travail
en choisissant tu sais le le
trois octobre fait que j'ai
j'ai par contre je suis pas
d'accord avec SW là-dessus moi
je pense que c'est un devoir de
citoyen de voter et je compte
remplir mon devoir mais euh
personnellement ça fait quand
même quelques campagnes que je
fais pis je pense que ça a
jamais influencé euh mon vote
ben oui moi c'est ce que
j'allais dire parce que ça nous
fait prendre conscience de des
efforts du temps que que mettre
pas seulement les chefs mais
ceux qui qui l'accompagnent euh
alors quand on arrive à la fin
de la campagne ils sont remplis
d'espoir pis euh parfois ils
t'ont ils sont déçus parfois
ils sont contents ça nous
permet de comprendre ce qu'ils
ont ce qui est en jeu en fait
ce soir-là ils ont ouais si euh
moi j'ai souvent couvrir une
campagne t'es t'es tellement
privilégié tu sais d'avoir les
deux chapeaux de journalistes
pis d'électeurs parce que quand
t'arrives le trois octobre t'es
probablement parmi les les
mieux renseignés. Les mieux
outillés pour faire ton X et
moi je suis d'accord avec euh
avec Véronique tu sais ça ça
demeure un un devoir euh de de
citoyen pis au contraire c'est
c'est qu'on est bien outillé
pour faire ce choix-là parce
qu'on on voit aussi on le sent
là tu sais ce qui se passe dans
les autres caravanes on voit
les dynamiques pis on on les
programmes on a pas le choix de
mettre le nez dedans pis c'est
pas exact. C'est un peu ça.
Peut-être un petit rappel avant
de partir euh juste nous dire
Jacques-Audrey tu vas avec le
parti conservateur. À partir de
ce soir Alex c'est les extrêmes
politiques. C'est ça les okay.
Alexandre. Moi je m'en vais
avec les libéraux à partir de
ce soir. Sébastien. Parti
Québec ois? Moi je reste dans
un parti indépendantiste
souverainiste parce que je
rejoins donc Québec Solidaire
pour le reste de la campagne.
Exact. Et moi j'ai été avec le
Parti Libéral et je m'en vais
maintenant avec la Coalition
Avenir Québec. Alors je je
remercie tout le monde de nous
avoir écouté avoir donné cette
opportunité parce que chacun
dans nos autobus je pense qu'on
avait besoin de parler Ça nous
a fait du bien d'en parler en
groupe pis de se voir en
personne alors ça va être le
premier débat ce soir on va
surveiller ça. Merci tout le
monde de nous avoir suivi pis
si vous avez d'autres questions
vous pouvez nous les envoyer
par courriel, par Twitter, par
euh Facebook, nos nos adresses
personnelles. Ça va nous faire
plaisir d'y répondre. Bye.
Merci.